we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime that number
is 219 to david p
here is yet another caller who i fear
may be understating the importance of
voting if you're in a very blue or very
red state take a listen
hey david i have a quick question i
myself am from new york state
and on the subject of voting i'm
wondering those who
know that their county or state or
district or whatever is going to go
blue right you know regardless of the
individual
vote what would you say to people like
myself and others that uh
might not necessarily think that it's uh
worth going to the effort to
to vote by mail um or just to vote at
all
yeah so i would tell you you are very
very wrong this election
in particular is a crucial election
in which we have to run up the score by
that i mean
we need votes for biden in blue states
that biden will win easily
and we need votes for biden in red
states that biden will very much lose
because the larger the margin the more
difficult it will be for a court
to give anything to trump if he tries to
challenge the results
in one state nationally whatever it's
never been more important to vote than
this year
regardless of what's happening in your
state we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about coronavirus
and the sturgis motorcycle rally
it's not just usps it's also fedex
deliveries that are delayed i'll tell
you why
and my tesla stock my tesla stock down
21 in one day what the hell happened
did i sell any in advance i will give
you the full
rundown on today's bonus show don't miss
it become a member
at joinpakman.com to get instant
access to the bonus show